maybe playing up a little bit on Connors  things that have been previously said I  sense that there are different  approaches that well every foundation  your foundation as well takes to harness  change and a particularly positive  change in resolve issues I guess just to  sort of get a summary or a more  inclusive view on it what is your theory  of change oh one of the things in my  experience so far it's been most  effective bridging leadership being  phenomenally inclusive to all  stakeholders and developing  relationships of mutual trust and  respect if you have the mutual trust and  respect your bridge leadership across  the multiple stakeholders I've seen  amazing things happen